Computers are really good at following instructions,
but those instructions have to be precise and detailed.
For example, if you ask the computer to sort your files without giving much detail,
it won't know which files you want to sort or whether you want to sort them by name,
or date, or size.
There's a lot of unanswered questions in this command here.
A more precise list of instructions would be to tell the computer
step-by-step exactly what to do: open this particular folder,
go through all the files in it,
find the most recent one,
and then place it at the top,
and repeat that for the remaining files.
This list of instructions here answers all possible questions that a computer may have.
And so, it would happily follow them without any problems.
So, those list of instructions here should be told to
the computer in the language it understands, like Java.
Java Language is a computer language that uses
basic English words but in a very specific way that computers can understand.
It offers a huge library of
instructions and commands that you could just use straight away,
like this one for example which you'd probably use a lot in this course.
This command here instructs the computer to
display something on the screen like a text message,
or the result of a calculation,
or a decision that the computer just made.
It's written as follows: system dot out dot print line,
shortened to 'println,' followed by those set of parentheses here,
and then terminated with this semi-colon at the end.
This is a computer system command that displays
some text as an output by printing it to the screen as a new line.
But what does it print exactly?
Anything you write within those set of parentheses here.
So say we want to printout this message, "Hello, World!"
then that's what we write in there.
So once you run this command, the message "Hello, World!"
will be displayed.
Sounds simple enough.
However there's a few things that we need to take
extra care when we're writing Java programs.
Let's have a look at a few.
First of all, it's important to know that Java is case sensitive,
which means that capital letters and small letters matter.
So if we try to write this command like this, system.out,println();
just exactly the same but with a small s,
then Java won't really understand what
we're saying and it won't be able to run that command.
Also note that I've used those quotation marks here.
That's because we want to display this message "Hello, World!"
exactly as we typed it in.
We will see other options later on.
Finally, this little semi-colon at the end here,
tells the computer that this is the end of this instruction.
Anything else I type after that is the beginning of a new instruction.
This is really handy when we get to
more complicated instructions that can be written in multiple lines.
Now, why don't you go ahead and try this yourself.
After this video, you can edit this statement here and run your own program.
Try to change this message here to display "Java Rocks!"
instead of "Hello, World!"